I ordered for idli sambar and this pool
is put in it so as he was putting the
spoon I grabbed it from his hand I run
my thumb on it it was greasy
I took a smiie a sniff of it it was
already smelling of somewhere it's been
reused you know plastic has got so many
chemical complexes in it phthalates
chill aids bisphenol this cause cancer
these leach into food they don't
biodegrade but still we using whole lot
of plastic disposable cutlery why are we
doing this answer obviously is there is
no alternative oh well we have an
alternator now we come up with an
alternative and that is edible cutlery
here there is no coating in fact it is
entirely delicious you can eat up the
spoon delicious it is made of dough are
blended with rice and wheat without
preservatives just like dehydrated
vegetables our product also has a very
long shelf life or more than three years
in fact you can even have a hot soup
also you can stir your sugar and have
your tea
you can eat it up you don't want to eat
it
you can just throw it it decomposes
within 4 to 5 days which was never my
labor they collected some Gmail
Maruyama start ok come to rukia bar is
ahmed al k upon kiya both tasty data
madam
[Music]
[Music]
applica be arnica too much guevara me
sooner I for example did you Papa got
spoon folk art angry though spoon cup
flavor I got is my jeera adjoin rock
salt black pepper malate or risk of big
cart a drop top spoon kappa no sir spoon
Nicorette epic jowar roti khaled when it
comes to financing this i had to put the
only ascent that I have which is a flat
where I am residing as a collateral
security and then got the low because
there's no such technology we are the
first in the world so the technology had
to be created
[Music]
I brought in this edible cutlery and
trying to promote a market for millets
and motivate farmers to move away from
rice plastic is very cheap true but I
can make it as cheap I can with volumes
and once when I get the volumes I get on
to the farmers directly and start
procuring raw materials directly from
the farmers in which case my spoons will
be as stiff as a past exposed
[Music]
so now the cutlery is tasty fun
nutritious and environment-friendly
that's edible cutlery
you
[Music]